[Aplausos]
y es el país de la libertad
desde el comienzo del siglo 21 eeuu es
una de las pocas naciones en las que se
ha reducido el acceso al aborto en
algunos de sus estados mientras tanto
decenas de otros países muchos de ellos
conservadores tomaron medidas para
legalizar o ampliar la interrupción del
embarazo
uno de ellos es irlanda tradicionalmente
católica anuló la prohibición del aborto
en el 2018 en una votación arrasadora
fue el sexto referéndum sobre el aborto
en el país
por su parte varios países de américa
latina han legalizado el procedimiento
en los últimos años es el caso de
colombia y argentina
y en méxico el tribunal supremo
dictaminó el año pasado que era
inconstitucional castigar el aborto a
mujer alguna que aborte pero sigue
siendo ilegal en la mayoría de los 32
estados mexicanos en octubre del 2021 en
el continente africano los
parlamentarios de benin votaron a favor
de la legalización del aborto en la
mayoría de los casos hasta las 12
semanas una victoria importante para el
continente que cuenta con una gran parte
de los aproximadamente 20 países en los
que el aborto sigue siendo completamente
ilegal sin embargo el acceso al aborto
sigue amenazado en todo el mundo
polonia endureció polémicamente la
legislación a finales del 2020
convirtiéndola en una práctica ilegal e
incluso en los países en los que el
aborto se legalizó hace décadas suele
haber una discrepancia entre lo que dice
la ley y lo que ocurre en la realidad en
túnez por ejemplo el aborto se legalizó
en algunos casos en
1965 8 años antes del caso roe versus
wave en 1973 pero hasta la actualidad la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
sigue siendo un tabú y a menudo está
fuera del alcance sobre todo para las
mujeres solteras